.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
IF YOU'VE BEEN PAYING ATTENTION
FOR THE PAST FEW YEARS, AND IF
YOU'RE WATCHING THIS SHOW, WE
HOPE YOU ARE, THERE HAS LIKELY
BEEN A MOMENT WHEN YOU REALIZE
THAT REALITY IS NOT QUITE WHAT
YOU THOUGHT IT WAS.
A LOT OF THE THINGS YOU ASSUMED
WERE TRUE IN FACT ARE NOT TRUE.
THEY ARE INSTEAD A MIRAGE.
THEY ARE A WEB OF PURPOSE BUILT
MYTHS DESIGNED TO DECEIVE RATHER
THAN INFORM YOU.
YOU CAN'T REALLY TRUST YOUR
SENSES ANYMORE.
YOUR EYES WILL LIE TO YOU.
THAT'S AN UNNERVING THOUGHT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU REALIZE THAT
ULTIMATELY VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
BEHIND IT ALL.
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION IS
EVERYWHERE IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S LURKING EVEN WITHIN OUR OWN
MINDS.
IT'S WORTH EVEN ADAM SCHIFF TOLS
IT WAS FAIR LAST WEEK
THOUSANDS OF SOUTHWEST AIRLINES
FLIGHTS FAILED TO LEAVE THE
GROUND.
IT SEEMED OBVIOUS THAT THE MASS
CANCELLATIONS WERE A DIRECT
REACTION TO JOE BIDEN'S VACCINE
MANDATES.
THEY WERE ANNOUNCED DAYS BEFORE.
THAN ACTUAL SOUTHWEST PILOTS
APPEARED TO CONFIRM IT.
BUT NO, THAT'S JUST WITH THE
KREMLIN WANTS YOU TO THINK.
IN FACT, AND THE AUTHORITIES
ASSURED US ALL ALONG, IT WAS
ONLY THE WEATHER.
NOTHING MORE THAN A FEW CLOUDS.
CALM DOWN, AMERICA.
THAT SOUTHWEST AIRLINES STORY IS
AS FAKE AS HUNTER BIDEN'S
LAPTOP.
DON'T LET THE RUSSIANS LIE TO
YOU.
PEOPLE LOVE THE VACCINE
MANDATES.
EVEN THE THOUSANDS WHO HAVE BEEN
FIRED BECAUSE OF IT.
THEY THEY KNOW PERFECTLY WELL
HOW NAUGHTY THEY'VE BEEN.
THEY NEED DISCIPLINE AND THEY
KNOW HOW TO GET IT.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, MAY
HAVE ANOTHER.
THERE'S A REASON JOE BIDEN IS
THE SINGLE MOST POPULAR HEAD OF
STATE IN AMERICAN HISTORY AND
THE REASON IS HE'S AWESOME.
HOW BELOVED IS JOE BIDEN?
LET'S PUT IT THIS WAY.
AT SPORTING EVENTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, FANS ARE BREAKING OUT
IN CHEERS FOR THE WHITE HOUSE
AND ITS WISE AND ELEGANT LEADER.
THESE ARE NOT COORDINATED
POLITICAL SET PIECES, ASTROTURF,
AS WE SEE IN WASHINGTON BABIES
ARE SPONTANEOUS ERUPTIONS OF
LOVE.
ONE MINUTE YOU'LL BE WATCHING
COLLEGE FOOTBALL FROM THE STANDS
IN THE NEXT MINUTE YOU'LL BE
OVERCOME WITH A DESIRE, THE
PRESSING, IRRESISTIBLE NEED TO
TELL JOE BIDEN HOW GREAT HE IS.
IT'S LIKE HAVING TO GO TO THE
BATHROOM REAL BAD EXCEPT BETTER
AND MORE PROGRESSIVE.
THIS IS HAPPENING, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, AND IT'S HAPPENING
EVERYWHERE.
A CRESTING TSUNAMI OF SUPPORT
FOR JOE BIDEN.
HERE'S A SAMPLE.
>> [BLEEP] JOE BIDEN.
[BLEEP] JOE BIDEN.
>> Tucker: IT'S INSPIRING,
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
JOE BIDEN ON HIS FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE PROMISED TO BRING THIS
COUNTRY TOGETHER AND NOW HE'S
ACTUALLY DOING IT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT TEAM YOU
SHOWED UP TO ROOT FOR.
IN YOUR HEART, YOU'RE A
JOE BIDEN FAN, AND THAT'S
NATIONAL UNITY.
NOT EVERYONE IS FOR THIS, OF
COURSE.
TO VLADIMIR PUTIN, WHO HATES US
FOR OUR FREEDOMS AND ALSO
BECAUSE HE'S RUSSIAN, THIS IS A
THREAT.
LOVING BIDEN IS A THING OF
BEAUTY, SO MY DEFINITION
VLADIMIR PUTIN MUST DESTROY IT.
IT'S LIKE A SUNSET, A ROSE
GARDEN, A BABY'S SMILE.
IT'S SOMETHING LOVELY THAT MUST
BE DEFILED IF RUSSIA IS GOING TO
DOMINATE THE WORLD.
SO IN ORDER TO CORRECT WHAT IS
GOOD AND BEAUTIFUL, PUTIN HAS
SPREAD THE LIGHT OF THESE
EXPRESSIONS OF YOUR DEVOTION TO
JOE BIDEN ARE INSTEAD ATTACKS ON
JOE BIDEN, FOLDER ATTACKS THAT
INCLUDE AN EPITHET BEGINNING
WITH F.
SADLY, A LOT OF PEOPLE BELIEVE
THAT.
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION IS
AFFECTED.
THAT'S WHY THEY DO IT.
THANK HEAVEN NBC HAS BEEN THERE
TO CORRECT THAT MISPERCEPTION.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS, AND
BCS MAY BE DONE MORE THAN ANY
NEWS ORGANIZATION IN THIS
COUNTRY TO FIGHT THE
KREMLIN'S PROPAGANDA MACHINE.
THANKS TO NBC, FOR EXAMPLE, YOUR
DOUBTS ABOUT THE FAIRNESS OF THE
LAST ELECTION OF NOT ONLY BEEN
SETTLED.
THEY ARE NOW ILLEGAL.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO EXPRESS
THEM EVER AGAIN.
SO WE CAN BE THANKFUL THAT THERE
WAS A CREDENTIALED REPRESENTED
EVENT OF NBC SPORTS ON HAND
EARLIER THIS MONTH WHEN FANS AT
A NASCAR EVENT BEGAN TO
CELEBRATE SPONTANEOUSLY
CELEBRATING JOE BIDEN.
IF THE NBC LADY HAD NOT BEEN
THERE, YOU MIGHT VERY WELL HAVE
MISHEARD WHAT THE CROWD SAID.
WATCH.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
SUCH AN UNBELIEVABLE MOMENT.
>> BRANDED, HE ALSO TOLD ME.
YOU CAN HEAR THE CHANTS FROM THE
CROWD.
LET'S GO, BRANDON.
>> Tucker: F JOE BIDEN.
PLEASE, COME ON.
WAKE UP COME AMERICA.
IT'S LIKE LOOKING INTO A
THRIVING CREDIBLY ROBUST ECONOMY
AND CONCLUDING THERE'S
INFLATION.
SETTLED ON, VLADIMIR PUTIN,
THAT'S PARTICULARS.
WHAT THEY SAID AND YOU CAN HEAR
IT CLEARLY IF YOU OPEN YOUR EARS
TO THE TRUTH, IS "LET'S GO,
BRANDON."
THE NBC LADY MADE THAT VERY
CLEAR.
NOT F, JOE BIDEN.
LET'S GO, BRANDON.
WHO IS BRANDON, YOU ASK?
ANOTHER HAPPY AMERICAN GRATEFUL
FOR THE WISE LEADERSHIP OF HIS
BENEVOLENT PRESIDENT.
BRANDON IS A NEWLY ARRIVED
AMERICAN, PART OF WHAT WE CALL
THE BIDEN GENERATION.
HE'S AN UNDOCUMENTED
TRANSPORTATION MIGRANT
CONTROLLED IS A FILM STUDIES
MAJOR AT NYU.
BRANDON IS THE EMBODIMENT OF THE
NEW AMERICAN